bonjour à tous ceux soyez les bienvenus
à cette autre émission en direct sur
facebook live sur le site d' espace
autochtone également sur radio canada
c'est notre dernière émission de l'année
2018 et aujourd'hui nous allons la
consacrer
non pas l'appropriation culturelle mai
à une réflexion sur l'appropriation
culturelle au lendemain de la
controverse kanata alors pour le faire
des invités ici à montréal charles
bender comédiens bonjour charles
oui merci merci d'être là merci isabelle
picard
bonjour bonjour isabelle vous êtes une
spécialiste des premières nations vous
êtes chargé de cours à l'université du
québec à montréal vous enseignez quel
genre de cours être du ksar au monde
autochtone entre autres lois la
gouvernance au féminin pour les
autochtones c'est très bien donc on
n'aura pas l'occasion de parler ça
aujourd'hui mais j'imagine que ce que
vous enseignez va se retrouver ou dans
cette conversation aujourd'hui et nous
allons à québec rejoindre un troisième a
vite et c'est michel nadeau il est co
auteur de la pièce kanata et hillel
directeur artistique du théâtre
l'aborder à québec monsieur nadeau
bonjour bonjour bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté cette invitation
alors première question au lendemain de
cette controverse kanata qu'elles le
sont
tiré de ce scandale je sais pas si je
devrais parler de scandale mais elles ne
sont devrait-on en tirer qui a envie de
se lancer dans la conversation en
premier ben moi je dirais de suite en
partant que ce qui est extrêmement
dommage jusqu'à présent avec tout ce qui
se passe autour de kanata c'est que
personne semble se souvenir de ce qui
était réellement écrit dans des deux
lettres qui ont été envoyés par le
groupe adopte qui avait été formé pour
demander aux créateurs de kanata
d'engager la conversation il n'y a
jamais été question de vouloir censurer
ou de vouloir annuler les
représentations dansées dans aucune de
ces deux lettres là et pourtant pour une
raison ou pour une autre le message qui
a été distribué le message a été lancé à
la population générale c'est que c'était
ça l'objectif qu'on demandait et ça
c'est le problème le plus criant
en ce moment je pense dans tout le débat
qui a entouré cette pièce là l'on est
rendu qu'on va parler du résultat de la
pièce alors que c'était pas le résultat
qu'on voulait qu'on voulait c'est pas
passé par rapport au résultat qu'on
voulait engager un dialogue c'était par
rapport au processus
et ça c'est dommage parce que en ce
moment le message ils pensent produit
tout ce qu'on entend c'est qu'il ya des
gens qui ont essayé de censurer un
spectacle alors que ça n'a jamais jamais
été le cas oui monsieur nadeau de votre
côté vous j'imagine que vous en avez
discuté avec monsieur de pages aviez
vous l'impression qu'il y avait qu il
était question de censure derrière ça
non c'est pas l'un c'est pas
l'impression du tout qu'on entre comme
moi j'ai eu je pense pas que que c'est
l'impression que robert rue je pense
plus jusqu'où je pourrais bien mais je
pense pas l'avoir entendu parler de
censure c'est évident qu'après la la
lettre qui a eu les premières lettres
dans le devoir et la rencontre qu'ils
ont eue et puis après la rencontre donc
comme quand les ce que les médias en ont
rapporté évidemment avec un angle avec
un landau qui ont voulu y donner c'est
sûr que des je pense que du
mécontentement particulièrement dans les
réseaux sociaux et que mécontentement
tel que l'a certainement le diffuseur
new york qui a décidé de retirer ses
billes du projet ça a eu pour
conséquence d'annuler le projet mais je
pense pas de coop mois pour avoir
évidemment parlé avec ariane mnouchkine
avec avec robert lepage
après coup c'était évident que les
cellules 3 pour nous que la lettre
qu'elle était vraiment parlé du
processus parler de bon qu'est ce qu'on
fait c'est malheureux qu'on y soit pas
bon et c'était une invitation au
dialogue et c'est toujours été pris
comme tel puis dans les réponses je
crois aussi a toujours l'oeil
une distinction qui a été fait c'est à
dire qu'ils avaient déjà qu'il voulait
parler il ya des gens qui étaient qui
trouve ça dommage que qu'ils soient pas
là mais c'est bon il ya certaines
personnes disaient c'est plate mais
maintenant le processus est tellement
avancée qu'on comprend que on espère que
ça se reproduira plus une chose comme ça
d'autres étaient plus vindicatif il
voulait pas du tout que ça ben oui c'est
pas par l'unil est bon avec le may a pas
été question que pour ariane mnouchkine
et pour robert lepage jamais que parce
que par rapport aux légendes les
signataires de la lettre est leur but
est évidemment ce n'est pas de créer de
la censure mais après seul comme je vous
dis les réactions fait que une
annulation après coup au tibet c'est une
sorte de censure au second degré le
fêter mais mes autres pour être pour
revenir sur ce que charles disait c'est
évident pour nous que le lait le sel
invitation au dialogue et non pas
un désir d'annuler les spectacles se
déclare alors le dialogue
même si la controverse bon est derrière
nous le dialogue maintenant doit
s'amorcer doit se poursuivre isabelle
absolument mais malheureusement ce que
charles disait c'est très fort et c'est
très laid encore en fait semaines sur
facebook je lisais un chroniqueur du
journal de montréal qui disait on a
empêché le génie créatif de lepage et de
moushin par des curés de la rectitude et
des censeurs je donne des trucs comme ça
moi je suis juste plus capable on peut
pas avoir un dialogue quand de l'autre
côté on semblait de si mauvaise foi est
ce que j'ai fait j'ai fait un rappel
justement à la première lettre
relisez le on n'est pas les gens
semblent tout mélanger slave bon les
protestations avec les pancartes de
racisme on est on est là dans l'autre
est vraiment vraiment autre chose c'est
des événements qui sont arrivés coup sur
coup mais il faut pas faut pas tout
mélanger
bon j'ai refusé de participer à un panel
sur l'appropriation culturelle parce que
je me sens pas à l'aise de le faire je
me sens plus à l'aise je trouve qu'il ya
trop de mauvaise foi qui malheureusement
ça ça brime notre liberté d'expression
c'est vraiment dommage est ce qu'il ya
une mauvaise foi parce qu'il y à un
conte préhension et parce qu'il ya
méconnaissance
mais si je peux me permettre on a
ressenti un peu la même chose nous aussi
c'est à dire que après la rencontre
qu'on a vu à montréal quand ghannouchi
est venu pour naïve leur encontre
suivent la date exacte il y avait des
gens qui avaient dit de la communauté
autochtone qui avait dit ben les deux
rives qui nous séparent sont moins
éloignées l'une de l'autre une volonté
de créer des dépôts et quand on
souhaitait laisser
il était 11h 11h30 le soin c'était
l'impression qu'on avait tout le monde
est resté très cordiale même pour la
majorité des gens qui ont un plat côté
après bon après la cérémonie
après la rencontre c'est à dire et le
lendemain bon il ya des médias très peu
qui ont rapporté ce qu'ils ont dit ça se
rapproche bon et des ponts qui sont des
mains tendues et cetera et cetera mais
c'était vraiment marginale chez radio
canada avait rapporté ça de cette façon
là je me souviens maintenant la plupart
de la presse écrite c'était le canada se
fera sans nous et à la terreur et donc
oui ce qui a été rapporté l' angle
critique
avec lequel on rapportait la chose
laissé entendre qu'il y avait que
c'était but est que c'était un incompris
c'était une fin dans le savoir alors
qu'il contexte de production
particuliers aussi donc évidemment ça
cent mille feux cent mille feux dans
forêts et ses rites sacrés dans un peu
ce qu'isabelle dit no 6 a fait que ce
qui s'est passé vraiment c'est pas là
dessus qu'on s'est quitté il a sa part
dans une direction et précise les
réseaux sociaux embarqué c'est hors de
contrôle et puis c'est très dommage
parce que c'était poster montre que le
feeling qu'on avait c'était comme on se
parlait puis avait des choses qui
s'éclaircit sais pas il y avait des
choses que peut-être réduire être
apprêtée fait preuve la belle impression
une compréhension mutuelle qui
commençait à s'amorcer et l'autre camp
c'est parti tout cela qu'est-ce que vous
voulez qu'on fasse
vous étiez tous les deux signataires des
deux lettres qui ont été publiés un mois
là de la dernière fois la première
réaction des vacances d'accord mais non
plus j'avais pas si la première pour une
raison très bien il ya deux raisons en
fait la première raison étant que
j'étais pas disposer pour l'assignation
moment là j'étais sur la rue larrey
tenait juste d'être écrite j'avais lu le
premier
la première version des choses là dedans
avec lesquels je suis plus ou moins
d'accord je sais pas si c'est le bon
message à passer ses messages là que
j'ai pas eu l'occasion de changer ses
dires on a besoin de comédiens
autochtones dans le spectacle et moi je
me disais ballon on a besoin c'est
beaucoup plus larges comme demandes de
toute façon ses patins
parce qu'être comédien dans un spectacle
comme celui là nous aurait mis à risque
de jouer l'autochtone de services chose
que moi j'avais produit nous les pensons
pas que je connais à peu près personne
dans mon groupe pourrait décider de le
faire on aurait voulu être impliqué en
ans créateur on a réussi à créer le
dialogue on arrive mais ce pouvoir être
évitée pouvoir échanger avec les acteurs
étaient là pouvoir proposer aussi notre
manière de fonctionner et le temps
approchait restait vraiment pas beaucoup
de temps parce que le spectacle existait
depuis déjà trois ans et demi à ce
moment là donc tout d'un coup on était
face à une situation ce qu'on était
comme son décide de s'engager ne reste
pas beaucoup de temps pour essayer de
proposer des choses mais une 1e
questionnements qui sortait de cette
halle est là et je pense que c'est là
dessus qu'on aurait dû insister ou qui
on aurait pu insister on est là c'est
dire mais ça fait longtemps que le
processus est entamé
pourquoi est ce que cette réflexion-là
pas eu lieu avant alors qu'il y avait
déjà des drapeaux rouges qui avaient été
soulevés il y avait des gens parmi les
consultants qui avec avait déjà commencé
à lever certains drapeaux moore a posé
certaines questions à dire juste ça se
passe peut-être pas comme vous pensez
que ça va se passer
il y avait des exemples probants qui est
en train de se faire au même moment il y
avait la création du world watch aux
propos parler de ma propre co mais il y
avait déjà le sm qui est en train de
créer un spectacle dont on parle pas de
gens qui sont en train de travailler
dans des sous-sols d'église l'on parle
de très grandes institutions qui est en
train de proposer des choses
intéressantes pour se demander mais
pourquoi est ce que la réflexion avait
pas eu lieu avant et pourquoi est ce
qu'on se limite aux limites en matière
doit fonctionner convient pas bons on
you tube relié de deckard cannes et des
encarts cannes et tout ce qu'on est en
train de faire en ce moment
voilà si oui à l'ewi alesi monsieur la
douve
oui c'est bon ok ben si je peux
évidemment pas producteur un donc je
suis co auteur mais mais ce que je sais
c'est que parce que c'est souvent des
idées et des contextes des choses
contextuel puis souvent comme dans des
productions théâtrales ou des rencontres
des compagnies ou des coproductions
c'est souvent le fait de personnes n'a
envie de travailler bon il ya des cas il
ya un truc très particulier à chaque
fois chaque aventure et la serial mouche
kinky bon juste un petit rappel très
bref le théâtre du soleil la directrice
artistique du théâtre du soleil c'est la
deuxième plus grande compagnie française
après la comédie française
ça fait cinquante quatre ans que ça
existe et elle est la créatrice est
l'unique metteur en scène depuis 54 ans
il ya peut-être quatre ans elle avait
invité robert lepage et le deal c'était
je t'offre m'accompagner voilà qu'est ce
que tu vas en faire et comme c'était une
compagnie le terme du soleil qui a
toujours qui montrent un shakespeare mhz
avec une esthétique du kabuki japonais
qui vont monter une tragédie grecque
avec en s'inspirant de culture orientale
indienne tamouls et cetera et cetera
dans le robert dimanche sur m6
je suis un admirateur du théâtre du
soleil d'ariane mnouchkine donc c'est
une très grande invitation mois jusque
j'ai proposé c'est ce qu'on a ici à
l'ouest et non pas l'orient à l'occident
c'est l'histoire bon la culture
autochtone et comme lui avait fait des
spectacles déjà avec l'uaw en date avec
le cirque du soleil n'était grands aussi
d un artiste de quoi bondir à il a dit
dans certaines entrevues ici uteq la
naïveté de penser qu'il avait qu'il
était autorisé à faire un spectacle
autour de soi comme il en avait déjà
fait ça va jamais créé de problème et
c'est évident que si il avait dit par
exemple on vend reçu un spectacle autour
du génocide culturel et que ça prendrait
disons des débuts aussi cet acteur des
premières nations sûrement qui regarde
je leur ai dit non non ce que je t'offre
sais c'est ma compagnie que je me disais
alors qu'il soit sur un autre projet
futur ailleurs mais mais il sait que ça
s'est passé comme ça et c'est pour ça
qu'il ya beaucoup de consultations de
rencontrer des gens beaucoup
bon on s'est documenté on de l'uimm
l'intrus etc et oui à des gens qui avait
dit attention comme charles mais
processus est en cours et puis on
sincèrement pensez pas que ce serait sa
fresque ce que ça a fait et comme lui
beaucoup de consultations rencontrer des
gens beaucoup et la nation huronne
wendat l'ancienne lorette parce qu'il y
avait un épisode qui se passait en 1825
spécifiquement alors et il ya des gens
qui étaient très positifs aussi déjà que
12e louis bref c'est intéressant que
vous en parliez
assurez vous d'avoir des bonnes
informations alors il y avait des gens
qui dit oui et encore il ya des gens qui
disent go parler de ça mais des gens qui
disent non et leur site
et si ce lot de coups qu'on sent que
mais le processus s'est elle est engagée
de telle façon que c'est très difficile
de d'intégrer de recul et de faire autre
chose
il ya un contexte de production une
pression aussi voilà enfin je veux dire
là dessus en fait ce que je trouve dans
l'exemple précis de qanater ce qui m'a
interpellé moi même et pour laquelle la
raison pour laquelle j'ai écrit déjà
deux chroniques l'habitude dans la
presse oui c'est qu'on prétendait faire
une relecture de l'histoire du canada à
travers le pressing des relations entre
autochtones et allochtones et je ne
sentait absolument pas que les
autochtones étaient représentés on est à
une époque où on parle énormément de
réconciliation you la commission vérité
réconciliation qui est mis 94 appel à
l'action dans tous les domaines
universitaires médias et caetera et
notamment dans les domaines artistiques
et je pense que par une relecture sans
intérêts je devrai ac ou convenablement
les autochtones pour moi moi samos ça me
chicotait parce qu'en fait pour une
relecture en fait on fait une autre
lecture
c'est ce que j'ai fait pour moi moisson
ma sensibilité autres que celles
auxquelles s'est déclenchée oui parce
que puis en région s'associent je veux
dire c'est sûr que l'argument des
gitanes et je suis sûr que monsieur
nadeau a déjà entendu ces arguments là
aussi il ya la déclaration des nations
unies sur les droits des autochtones
c'est pas juste une question se pose
c'est pas quelque chose qui force les
gens à agir d'une certaine manière mais
une reconnaissance internationale de
quelque chose qui a été oublié et été
omis dans le traitement qu'on fait des
peuples minorisées et ce à travers le
monde
entrons que les autochtones du canada
et puis ça c'était déjà en place à ce
moment livrent déjà une réflexion qui
peut être faite autour de ça et il ya
aussi l'aspect de le taire d'ariane
mnouchkine fait un travail louable et
extraordinaire de parler souvent au nom
de deux plaques minorisées qui ont
l'occasion de prendre la parole nous
tuons pas les infrastructures pour
l'appareil pourra pas lever la main dire
j'ai quelque chose à dire
la différence c'est que là où on en est
rendu en tant qu'artiste d'autres
acteurs dont tant que peuple autochtone
je dire en général on commence à avoir
les outils la possibilité la voix pour
dire on aimerait avoir quelque chose à
dire
et puis quand semaine on se retrouve
dans une situation comme celle là on a
un peu l'impression et je ne joue pas
prêter des intentions du tout ni à rien
ni à robert évidemment mais quand c'est
ce premier projet est sorti on a
l'impression de se faire dire on va
raconter l'histoire à votre place nous
autres de dire maintenant on avait su
prendre la parole
on peut mais non on va le dire à votre
place parce qu'on pense pas que vous
avez les compétences pour le faire et je
suis sûr que c'est pas ce qu'il s'est
passé normalement est exactement mais
c'est quelque part le symbole qui autour
de ça c'est stop c'est pour ça qu'il ya
une réaction très épidermique qui peut
sortir dehors parce qu'on a l'impression
de se perdre ou non attends on veut dire
à ta place parce que t'es pas facile
oui c'est sûrement pas l'intention non
seulement pour les tensions mais ce nom
mais je comprends je comprends tout à
fait c'est à dire qu'un d'affaires qui
était dans les maladresses que eu dans
ce projet là puis ça aussi robert
l'avait noté c'est que justement cette
cette ligne de presse lequel qui était
l'histoire des autochtones revues ou le
rapport revu et revu par robert lepage
et c'est parce que ça c'est une ligne de
communication qui a été lancé comme ça
je sais pas quand je sais pas ou parce
que c'est pas d'un monde intervient pour
la mais effectivement c'est une fausse
piste d'un rapport même par rapport au
spectacle c'est à dire que jamais eu
l'intention de parler à la place des
premières nations tout ça c'était le
projet original originaire y avait testé
trois époques trois villes du canada et
c'était 3 artistes européens qui a levé
et kitsch par chacun un billet
particulier qui arrivait et qui par le
hasard des circonstances
avait une relation d'amitié avec eux ou
des personnes des premières nations et a
traversé tout d'un coup ils prenaient
connaissance conscience de ce qui se
passait et évidemment de l'action
délétère du canada sur célé culture
autochtone donc c'est toujours un
artiste repayer un pet en photographiant
d'acteurs qui rentrait c'était c'était
seul point de vue donc et une langue de
dire c'est l'histoire revue un autre une
relecture le une maladresse et ce tout
est parti de là et pas c'était pas sur
les spectateurs qui se bat quand c'est
fait c'est fait et c'est difficile de
revenir et il est évident aussi que
jamais jamais jamais jamais eu
l'intention de dire vous n'êtes pas ces
grands vous n'êtes pas assez et
évidemment c'est parce que je peux
comprendre que ça peut être perçu comme
ça mais jamais c'était le cas d'ailleurs
après l'accord entre à montréal qui
avaient hué quand déjà dit on n'est pas
visible on est on est peu visible on
n'est pas là et cela qu ariane
mnouchkine avait dit mais je vous offre
la cartouche et pendant deux mois le
jeune plage deux mois n'importe qui vous
pouvez venir faire un stage de création
il critique et kanata ou amener des
compagnies des premières nations des
projets vous avez des spectacles existe
déjà il ya une ouverture pour dire
écoutez c'est peut-être pas fait comme
comme mort il y aurait fallu un contexte
particulier entre comme et pour essayer
de réparer de toute façon il ya quand
même une offre pour présenter le fait
que oui comme vous dites pas raciste à
faire ça fait un lien par rapport aux
mains tendues pu mourir qui se rapproche
quand on parle au début oui et quand
même cette ouverture là pour essayer de
dire d'ail ou des maladresses mais voilà
mais jamais
cette intention là c'est bien évidemment
mais par la suite quand le communiqué de
presse de madame motion pour annoncer
que finalement qanater a fallu elle a
été très très dur oui enfin c'est pas si
longtemps je suis un peu surprise parce
que là on est après la rencontre avec
les autochtones et ses mots n'étaient
pas léger il était très lo on est très
lourd de sens montre que je les prie
très difficilement cette unité de presse
et c'est peut-être pour ça aussi que le
malaise demeure toujours énormément
crever l'abcès
comment au contraire construire à partir
de tout ça et continuer à évoluer
il faut juste que je suis quelque chose
aussi qui est quand même assez important
c'est que le moment où madame où chacun
d'eux fait son offre est une offre somme
toute très généreuse effectivement ça
que ça répond jusqu'à un certain point
une certaine demande qu'on aurait pu
faire c'est des plages une plage la
cartouche chiffre d'affaires pour deux
mois en avril ou en mai 2010 neuf monts
et comme pour le temps qu'on a pour
monter un spectacle créé quelque chose
qui serait d'une valeur équivalente ou
même qui pourrait se rapprocher de ce
qui a déjà été fait avec kanata c'était
à peu près impossible stress tests et
foncer dans un mur clary et puis ça ça
va aussi dans le temps qui était qui
était présente et qui est serait
disponible pour proposer quelque chose
comme soit pas ce moment l'on sente non
savait pas encore s'il y avait une
souplesse de ce côté là avant de pouvoir
même en discuter bien là on a eu
justement l'événement ce que madame
mouche keane a dit ben on va faire
kanata en france bon très bien c'est
vrai c'est pas un territoire canadien
donc vous à l'étang sécurité en france
est disposée à avoir deux manifestations
mais les arguments qui nous ont été qui
ont été servis pour dire que kanata
devrait avoir lieu quand même c'est
madame jacqueline qu'assistait décote de
loi européen pour dire à des autochtones
on a le droit de le faire parce que les
codes de droit européen doit permettre
selon moi j'ai fait bien ce que tu
connais le crime et leur écurie mento je
veux dire c'est que c'est exactement ce
qui est arrivé quand le l'amérique a été
colonisée ces décotes de loi européens
qui ont été forcés à des gens en
amérique
c'est quand même étonnant que les lois
européennes nous l'ont permis ce
maintenant c'est notre territoire et
j'ai dit mais c'est une maladresse mon
dieu et si jeta s'il y avait eu des gens
impliqués dans le processus ci avait du
monde qui avait pu parler avec avec
madame ou week end mais non mais attends
c'est pas un argument
utilisez si on fonce dans un piège
l'autre vient d'ouvrir la porte peut
tuer de marché dans un piège à ours la
lune la pluie va repartir avec leur a
pas de bon sens c'est exactement le
genre d'argument d'un colonialisme
immense qui viennent nous est servie par
ce moment c'est comme vélo attend non on
répondrait pas tout de suite parce que
sinon on va juste on va justement le
fait qu'on va jouer son va tendre va
tendre que le choeur show ouvre on va
envoyer un beau message de losne le mot
de cambronne ur et aux artistes
et puis on voit rappeler c'était quoi
exactement qui était dans la première
lettre autant pour le bénéfice des gens
qui étaient dans de la création dont
plusieurs comprenait très bien c'était
quoi notre position autant pour le
bénéfice des médias qui clairement dans
plusieurs des corps n'avait absolument
rien compris ou n'avais tout simplement
polluent l'air les lettres alors
maintenant il ya encore beaucoup
d'incompréhension donc comment comment
vous tuer cette incompréhension comment
ramener le dialogue et comment faire
pour que tous puissent comprendre ce que
vous voulez a mené comme message que
vous voulez faire comprendre mais
également laissé les créateurs continuer
à créer aussi là
mais peut-être dans un premier temps moi
je pense qu'il faut faire preuve de
bonne foi et d'honnêteté intellectuelle
ça serait déjà un bon départ j'ai pas
senti ça partout de la part de plusieurs
médias je parlais tout à l'heure de
certains comptes car j'ai eu à débattre
à la télévision avec avec un chroniqueur
particulier ça est extrêmement de
vraiment difficile parce que je sentais
pas que cette personne avait même lu la
lettre ou qu' il y avait une bonne foi
on parle même pas de la même chose là
donc il faut il faut s'informer comme il
faut je pense que c'est la première
chose à voir oui parce que j'ai encore
par envie de parler de l'appropriation
culturelle est ce que j'ai déjà parlé
d'appropriation culturel dans le cadre
de kanata moi non la ligne et les peurs
elle n'est pas clairement défini le para
maracana en particulier oui je parlais
plus du d'une collaboration d'une main
tendue de vue rien sur nous sans nous il
ya beaucoup de ça oui dans le discours
de plusieurs plusieurs autochtones qui
ont signé la lettre pour revenir sur wii
sur l'incompréhension dont vous parliez
c'est à dire je ne crois pas que tant
d'incompréhension que ce stade est que
l'on parle de co spécifique qui est
canal tonnes un point de départ et du
banc qui fait que effectivement il ya
peu l'intégration peut-être d'artistes
autochtones dès le départ bon mais ça
c'est un cas très particulier d'une
compagnie particulière avec moi on en a
parlé beaucoup beaucoup là et on
comprend son ok mais je pense pas qu'ils
aient tant d'incompréhension que ça
c'est à dire qu'ils on a quand même
parlé beaucoup il
et on comprend très bien que si tout à
coup et robert le toujours dit
d'ailleurs il disait dès le départ il y
six mois avec juste avec avec ex machina
j'avais voulu faire un spectacle sur le
génocide culturel avec ma compagne et au
québec
c'est évident que j'aurais je me serais
adjoint avec des compagnies autochtone
des artistes des bons c'est ce que
j'aurais fait parce qu'il l'a déjà fait
donc le désir de travailler ensemble
il est là il ya une compréhension
mutuelle à ce niveau-là qanater quelque
chose d'exceptionnel à cause du contexte
de scène de ce spectacle
alors je pense pas qu'il ya des
incompréhensions je pense qu'il ya des
choses qui se sont exprimés beaucoup
plus clairement à cause de cette
controverse pendant l'été dernier et il
ya le c'est clair je veux dire et je
pense qu'on peut il y avait kevin rudd
qui est le directeur artistique du
théâtre tokten centre national des arts
que jouer et pas si longtemps que ça
pièce de michel tremblay encore une fois
si vous le permettez
mais moi je reçois formidable je dirais
que tout à coup deux deux acteurs des
premières nations jouent en va pas de
même mère et deux fils qui se passe ce
plateau mont royal dans les années 50
et parce qu'un rapports mère-fils s'il
n'y a pas au maire fils aussi et ça leur
appartient aussi
donc l'idée c'est que l'histoire
l'histoire du monde y soit des cultures
appartient à tout le monde ce qui n'est
pas une justification pour dire ça
appartient à tout le monde donc on va
prendre personne deux autres projets 60
renoux le spo solaise parce que la
question mais je pense que
l'incompréhension impôts si c'est pas si
éloigné que ça c'est à dire que s'il ya
d'autres projets qui se font en
partenariat en coproduction a cédé 10
heures de travail ensemble ça va se
faire et de façon comme avec plein
d'autres projets en des compagnies
différentes je sais ce dont il est
question de la compréhension maintenant
c'est pas nécessairement de la part des
créateurs c'est la république saisit
aussi comment convoqua comment on va
recadrer certains de ces informations là
parce que effectivement
monsieur nadeau présente un super beau
cas de figure effectivement il ya encore
une fois pour le permettez qui avait été
jouée par ok je pensais pas à vancouver
mais dans ce que si aussi pour
comprendre qu' il ya un achat de droits
auprès de michel tremblay qui était fait
pour traduire et jouer la pièce à
vancouver avec ses deux acteurs l'appui
ausilio l'argument derrière qui est
super important se souvenir c'est que en
tant qu'acteur en tant que gens de
théâtre il ya personne dans mon
entourage me dit qu'il a envie de jouer
ce qu'il est on a envie de jouer à
l'extérieur de ça mais dis ça je
l'emmène de manière plus globale plus
global plus large en parle entre autres
à cause que j'ai la chance d'être le
président du comité de la diversité pour
le conseil québécois du théâtre c'est
une question d'inclusion c'est de
s'assurer que si on fait des projets
comme ça et robert wares donnait très
très bon exemple
monsieur la page on donnait très très
bon exemple au tnm cette année parce
qu'il va présenter son coriolan qui a
déjà été présentée à stratford qui était
une distribution extrêmement diversifié
d'ailleurs faut le souligner la
direction artistique de stratford depuis
déjà plusieurs années commence à créer
un momentum pour la diversification de
ses castes et de ses distributions qui
vont nourrir et certaines aiment pij de
ce que j'en comprends de la distribution
va être assez variés assez diversifiée
mais c'est important de se rappeler que
toutes les clés les outils qu'on peut
utiliser pour qu'ils aient une meilleure
diversification mais d'une plus grande
créa a évité une plus grande diversité
sur la scène sont importants pic amateur
était un bon outil pour ce poste juste
pour taper sur ce clou là mais ça a été
un bon goûter aux un bon outil pour le
faire et aussi par prendre conscience à
nos amis européens parce que mentionnait
tentons l'argument madame ou chicken
prendre compte pas comprendre conscience
à nos amis
européens surtout à eux qu'on n'ait pas
une image folklorique qui sort des roms
en douane été ou qui sortent de
l'épreuve ou des films hollywoodiens
mais enfin bref des choses et par le
sang c'est pour ça que c'est plus ce
site oui non non non c'est quand même
j'avais fini ceci dit je dois dire que
bon moi j'étais à la première et après
la première on se prenait l'avion
mais bon j'ai dû un peu quelques
critiques devant di figaro du monde non
et ce qui était intéressant aussi
indépendamment de tout ce qu'on a dit le
par rapport à la présence est tous là
mais pour nous c'est très très important
de présenter aussi justement qui n'était
pas l'image clichés c'est sûr que ce
n'est pas dans nos préoccupations en
france ou en europe
la com de la question des premières
nations n'existe pas donc mais c'est sûr
que tout à coup de voir ce qu'ils on n'a
pas pu aller aussi loin qu'on aurait
voulu parce qu'on a dû réduire le projet
donc c'est peut-être des fois des choses
qui paraissent un peu superficielle
parce qu'il y aura fallu vraiment
réduire mais s'est dit que doit cette
vision d'aidé parce qu'il ya plusieurs
types de gens des premières nations qui
sont là une productrice de maillet
quelqu'un dans la rue il ya quelqu'un
qui est un documentaire risque c'est
qu'ils sont nés source etc
mais c'était très très très intéressant
de voir que d'autres prennent conscience
de ça de ce que c'est de prendre
conscience aussi de ce que par rapport
aux pensionnats ce que le canadien a
fait c'est des choses qui n'existent pas
et donc
malgré tout ce qu'on a dit malgré tout
ce qui était arrivé plus bémol qu'on
peut mettre c'est à dire que ce dont je
suis fier aussi prendre tous et à toute
l'équipe c'est qu'on présente quelque
chose aussi et on met la lumière sur
quelque chose qui est complètement
ignoré en france
alors j'espère aussi que ça permettra
s'est joué dans le cadre du festival
d'automne à paris j'espère que ça
permettra aussi au festival d'automne
aux programmateurs de dire ben tiens on
va aller au canada
on va aller voir s'il ya des compagnies
qu'on pourra pas invités nous parce que
on ouvre la porte quelque chose qui
était complètement ignoré fonctionnant
sans cela c'est très positif de loisirs
malgré tout alors vous pensez que kanata
partie 1 la controverse pourrait venir
jusqu'au canada
je sais pas de l'impossible ça pourrait
vous pourrez toujours je ne sais pas
écouté là c'est présentement c'est le
rôle du soleil que le nez collé au
twitter de ça donc est ce qu un festival
comme le ft a ou le carrefour
international de québec pourrait acheter
le spectacle jeu ça pour ça ça suit il
n'y a rien de prévu pour l'instant je
crois oui je suis sous toute réserve
je suis pas dans les arcanes mais
j'aimerais bien que ça que ça vienne
j'aimerais bien que ce soit mais bon je
sais pas on verra que c'est que c'est
beau aussi
qu'est-ce que tu en très bas et et
financière c'est 35 acteurs plus une
équipe de sa cause et a traversé l'océan
c'est quand même assez sportive mais
l'a6 à travers ce sens il faudrait que
ce soit les acteurs qui vivent ici au
québec qui joue dans la pièce non
abp coûter sa carrière producteur jean
marc barr colle ça s'appelle partie 1
est ce que ça veut dire qu'il y aura
d'autres partis d'ailleurs ce ça va être
quoi la suite de kanata
je ne sais pas qu'est ce que ce sera la
suite de cannes à temps c'est-à-dire
comme en fait c'est parti à mai dans le
projet originel c'était un troisième
partie vancouver il averti en 1821 et
cetera la troisième partie c'était
vancouver et nous ça nous apparaît c'est
ce qui était à cause du contexte de la
reprise tout ça c'était le plus facile
pour nous à faire d'une part et parce
qu'aussi dans la troisième partie avant
que tout l'axé 2 contre 2 cela arrive
c'était déjà dans le spectacle y avait
déjà cette ce thème là c'était déjà à
travers leur l'artiste peintre est tout
ouïe est en rapport avec la pinte pamela
masik qui avait fait quelque chose par
rapport aux victimes de pickton
ils étaient 17 déjà en filigrane mais
c'est un sous-thème disons alors ça
avait après ce qui est arrivé c'est
devenu le thème principal est dominant
de la pièce est pour ça qu on aille en
tchéchénie robert lepage on dit bon ben
c'est hervé il ya quelque chose que
l'actualité ça se passe une réflexion à
faire là dessus
donc on va savoir la première partie va
être finalement notre ancien troisième
partie premier épisode donc exclure un
2e je sais pas cela dépendra d'un paquet
de choses ça dépendra de l'accueil la
réception ça dépend drogue mais pour
l'instant on fait le premier puis après
ça on verra pour la suite
d'accord
comment allez vous recevoir robert
lepage la prochaine fois vous allez leur
encontre et le cas échéant parce que
j'imagine qui aura encore éventuellement
il y aura on va laisser canada côté il y
aura d'autres projets qui vont être
éventuellement comment ça va se passer
le la poignée de main pour dire ok on
continue mais on veut travailler
ensemble et on va travailler ensemble si
c'est possible
justement j'ai été invité par le théâtre
jean duceppe à faire un panel avant
la pièce la face cachée de la lune oui
en avril pour parler de l'importance de
la lune broncher les premiers peuples
tout ça je trouvais ça super intéressant
et j'imagine qu'ils vont être leur jeu
j'ai très hâte de le rencontrer
je pense que le respect est très très
important je pense que je reconnais
quand même plusieurs choses que monsieur
lepage a fait maintenant je vais
toujours être dans le rien sur nous son
centre moi c'est ma devise
moi ça va toujours être ici on a des
discussions mais peut-être que ça
attendra autour de ça maintenant je suis
ouverte à sa vision des choses mais je
pense que le respect c'est la base dans
un premier temps peut pas avoir de
dialogue si on a pas on ne peut y rester
que si on n'a pas une ouverture puis une
écoute de porter dont benjamin andré
dans le même sens parce que déjà à 20
que l'épisode canada soulève arrive moi
j'avais déjà des discussions avec avec
avec gilbert voyons avec bernard gilbert
du diamant dans l'espace qui vont ouvrir
à venir des spectacles d'ici le de
montréal dans cet espace de robert
lepage
donc c'est sûr qu'on veut garder une
relation cordiale avec avec tout avec la
page avec son équipe parce qu'il ya la
possibilité d'aller plus loin dans la
collaboration quand j'ai recroisé
travers la page justement à cela près
quand j étais cet été on n'a pas une
très longue conversation parce que les
donnons ces croisés rapidement mais je
veux dire ça restées cordiales on s'est
quand même serré la main il ya personne
qui qui qui jeter un regard nul à
l'autre donc c'est sûr qu'il y en a
encore la possibilité d'aborder prévu
que la collaboration des traits d antan
puis je veux dire j'espère un jour
pouvoir retourner à la borde et aussi
parce que j'y suis allée pas longtemps
avec le wild west show fait qu on
s'était croisé à ce moment là donc je
dirais des portes qui sauvent pillaient
des possibilités de collaborer des
possibilités d'avoir des bons moments
ensemble et ce pour pas l'exclure yeux
un moment il ya un moment de tension
c'est tout à fait normal on peu près
n'importe quelle relation mais dans ce
cas ci
je pense que ce qu'on est en train de
dire c'est que cette fois ci on recule
repos aussi facilement que les autres
fois on va continuer à insister sur le
message qu'on a pensé parce qu'on pense
que c'est important on pense qu'on a la
voix de le faire qui c'est arrivé trop
souvent dans le passé
donc on a décidé bon ben on n'a pas la
force de maintenir le message il faut
qu'on recule il faut qu'on faut
construire cette fois ci on le fera
papillons seront de repos jusqu'à
l'événement du style
en effet non alors dernier mot de la fin
pour conclure parce que l'heure tourne
déjà isabelle picard vous aimeriez
terminé en nous disant quoi
bert au fait je j'aimerais qu'on puisse
continuer ce disque sur le longtemps
malgré que bon on a mangé des coups ça a
été difficile de porter d'autres
vraiment de limite et d'autre mais
j'espère que le public vaut quand même
avoir une certaine sensibilité est
rouvert c'est vraiment important cette
discussion là on parlait de
réconciliation on parlait que maintenant
on est capable de faire les choses qu'on
a peut-être une voix qu'on n'avait pas
avant
puis tant mieux on y voit de plus en
plus fort l'ips sélim abou sow
ce n'est pas parce que oms affirme que
leur doit ce recul est il ya un
territoire où on peut se rejoindre je
pense dans le milieu charles bajaj
abonde dans le même sens ça revient pas
mal à ce que je viens de julien comme si
je passe le territoire on peut se
rencontrer dans le milieu pays
évidemment il faut qu'on faut qu'on
établisse ça va être quoi la qualité de
notre relation à partir de maintenant
parce qu'elles étaient d'une certaine
qualité pendant très très longtemps dans
notre corps pendant 400 ans a été le
même type de relation maintenant que la
porte pour que les choses changent il ya
la reconnaissance qu'on a les outils
pour faire changer ça il faut juste que
les gens qui sont en place depuis
longtemps qui profitent de certains
privilèges que ce soit inconscient au
conscient puisse faire à ok oui mais on
a certes un privilège qu'on peut
partager avec toi donc faisons le on
voit la crise est là cette collaboration
de tout sens et michel nadeau pour vous
pour terminer ben je trouve que la lafa
que ma part importante c'est que là il
ya une bonne volonté part et d'autre de
la part des artistes ça m'apparaît
évidemment il ya une meilleure
connaissance l'un de l'autre notre coq
qui est apparu à travers tout ça est la
chose que je souhaite aussi c'est que
les rapports que nous avons les rapports
publics que nous avons soir à porter
correctement parce que des voix quand on
en parlait par rapport à la lettre par
rapport au compte rendu de la rencontre
de cas vu à montréal
si tout à coup dans le compte rendu
qu'il ya quelque chose qui dérape et
l'eau ça c'est extrêmement malheureux il
s'agit d'un crime division entre des
gens qui veulent essayer de se parler là
c'est très très j'espère que ça se
produit ça se reproduira plus voilà
merci à tous les trois d'avoir accepté
cette invitation de venir nous retrouver
sur le plateau d' espace autochtone je
vous souhaite de très joyeuses fêtes à
tous de bons spectacles à aller voir ou
à jouer en perspective
merci beaucoup et puis pour nos
spectateurs nous allons reprendre cette
émission le 11 janvier donc en 2019 et
nous parlerons pour cette première
émission de langue autochtone merci
beaucoup
bonne année à bientôt
[Musique]